good morning john what what this is a
corner of my office that i never use
i made a set for games with hank in the
year well god like 2015.
this is where i sit where i do other
things that aren't at a computer which
at the moment
and possibly for the long term is my
microscope station
i have a microscope now i'm very excited
about it it is nice
to be brought into a different world
that is
beautiful and less complicated
than the one i'm normally in which this
week has been a lot like i'd love to add
something helpful i don't have much to
add i think joe biden's gonna be
president in two weeks
i don't think that there will be a coup
i think that all of this is tremendously
destructive to democracy
and our country uh but i don't think
that we are headed into a civil war it's
very bad it's just not anywhere close to
that bad and in fact like what these
people
want us to think is that maybe there
will be a civil war because that's what
they want because they're idiots more
important than that though
i recently went to flathead lake where
it was
freezing literally there were beautiful
waves
of chunks of ice crashing onto the shore
and
because i have a microscope i was like
probably i won't find anything really
interesting
but i am gonna dip my bare hand
into this lake and pull out some water
i'm gonna collect every scrap of
vegetation that has made it through this
churning mass of grinding rocks
you know ice as rocks and maybe i will
find something cool
well john i've been looking at this
sample which is in this tank right here
i just saw something with my eyes which
i did not expect but i just turned the
camera on i'm going to walk through the
process of trying to take a look
at whatever this little thing is or
these little things there's a bunch of
them so right
here in this corner there are these
little white
dots that are moving around a little bit
and i'm going gonna try and
suck some of those up okay i got the
little shrimpy thing on there
that's exciting oh hopefully i did not
just murder him
i think i did murder him well first try
as a failure
now i can take the eyepiece out of this
and shove it in here
oh and then i can attach this to my
phone let's try to find whatever that
thing was
hello friend whoa what
oh my gosh what a big boy i didn't even
mean to grab this thing from this sample
and it's huge
it is i can actually see it on my slide
oh
man that's cool uh and we can zoom in
closer here
get a better look at his insides oh
drink the lake
okay well this is cool i still want to
see one of these little
shrimpy things i think i got one i did
he's zooming around in there
and this time i'm not gonna push down on
the cover slip this lighting does make
me look like a murderer
he's huge oh geez he's got little arms
in there there's a lot going on with
this guy
but i i still can't really tell you what
he is i'm a little upset that he can't
move around
oh and then there's this which is you
know still
huge oh man this sample is just teeming
with life can you believe i pulled this
out
of just like ice and i'm just like
grabbing
tiny drops at a time and it's got stuff
like that in there
see a little shrimpy i'm putting on my
coverslip i want to see one of these
things so bad
wow okay that's a whole different that's
a whole different experience
the other thing even the same thing is
this whoa
whoa look at his tail this thing is so
fun to play with journey to the micro
cosmos is currently having a kickstarter
for this microscope uh along with this
attachment that allows you to make
content with it we're also putting
together a little guide to help you get
started in your own journey to the micro
cosmos
or if you don't want to do that we also
have the whole channel where you can
come and watch us explore
and it's really wonderful it's a nice
break from things it's the most relaxing
part of my job actually i'd say by a
fair margin
john i'll see you on tuesday